so you mentioned this idea of bringing
something to the surface
which is really interesting so can you
maybe elaborate
the surface and what is there in the
depths
of things and how does ego dissolution
fits into that well aldous huxley talked
about
the brain as a reducing valve that we
have an enormous amount of information
so right now there's an air conditioning
sound in the background
but that's not crucial to what you and i
are doing talking to each other so we
kind of tune that out
you know there's all sorts of sights and
sounds there's incoming information
in all the different sense modalities
and we have to figure out
what's important to us and so the
mind in a way focuses a lot on
what are our core needs and and
we filter all the incoming information
that we get towards focusing on what our
court needs and we can even get to um
abraham maslow in the hierarchy of needs
about
survival needs belonging needs the steam
needs to
go on so i think what
what i mean by bringing things to the
surface is
that we tend to
not focus on a lot of things that are um
coming but we also push away things that
are difficult emotionally
difficult cognitively you know we all
know that we're on this very short
trajectory from birth to death but we're
not constantly thinking about dying
[Music]
although that can actually be helpful to
focus us
on what's really important traumas
are often suppressed um
conflicts we see in america and around
the world a kind of rise of
irrationality
where people push away their logic in
order for their emotional
tribal needs to be met a lot of people
are
suffering from early childhood traumas
of a different kind or abandonment
issues or
anything so we tend to focus on just you
know what we need to survive
and what we need for work and esteem and
so psychedelics
um by dissolving this ego control
or by with mdma kind of strengthening
our sense of self
um and our sense of self acceptance we
can bring in
other information that have previously
been too complicated or too painful
you don't think of psychedelics as
conjuring up something new
it is more revealing something that is
already there
i think that's a very crucial thing so
um
yes um um sasha shulgin who um
sort of the um godfather of mdma
you know he sort of rediscovered it and
brought it um
back into use he talked about his first
experience was with mescaline his first
psychedelic experience was with
mescaline
and he had a tremendous experience but
what he said about it was
he was having a human experience that
the mescaline was helping him access
rather than he was having a mescaline
experience
so that it's not like you pop a pill and
you always have the same kind of
experience as everybody else the
the experience is not contained in the
pill the pill opens you up and you have
an experience of yourself
sometimes these are experiences that
we've never consciously had
but you we can say right now that we
know that
um our body below the level of our
conscious awareness has all these
self-healing mechanisms
and we we don't modulate them
to a large extent by conscious control i
mean eventually we we are learning more
about the mind body and we learn about
the placebo effect how what we think is
the case but
but i think that there's experiences
that are below our level of
conscious awareness particularly once
we're adults that are more these unit of
mystical experiences sense of connection
you know i think kids are like this a
lot we kind of come from the void you
could say and you're born and you you
have
um a different way of processing
information
one interesting point about that has to
do with ketamine
which is you know been approved s
ketamine for
depression but it's used for anesthesia
and roughly one tens the anesthetic dose
is a psychedelic dose and when it's used
in anesthesia
there's what's called the emergent
phenomena so this is you get
enough uh ketamine for um you can be
operated on you're not in pain you're
not really there your ego's knocked out
but you can still breathe but as the
operations
get over and then people metabolize the
ketamine
there's a process that they call the
emergent phenomena it's like as you're
emerging from this
tranquilized state and that's where you
pass through the psychedelic phase and
they don't prepare people for that
and what we see is that a lot of adults
have difficult times with that
but children don't seem to have that
those problems children are a little bit
more
already in this kind of state and so
ketamine is
is used quite frequently in children now
for anesthesia
so all of that is to say to your
question that um
i think it these psychedelics reveal
things that are within us
some things that are how we process
information back when we are children
um other things that we've never thought
of before that are sort of
baked into our consciousness um
you know there's one um drug 5-meodmt
it's this toxin from a sonoran toad
that many people consider it to be the
most powerful of all the psychedelics
and it kind of knocks the ego structures
completely out of it
and we experience something different
but it's something i think that's always
within us it's a deeper layer so we
knock out some of the higher cognitive
functions and then we experience things
in a different way
so my sense is that these are human
experiences that the psychedelics
bring us to
you